[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and it's time to go ashes
to ashes and dust to dust as we get into
The Groovy new horror movie Evil Dead
rise throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down the film and talking
about all the Easter eggs in it that
call back at the earlier movies now that
this isn't centered around Ash we
actually get a lot of nods and
references to the other films with us
even getting a Bruce Campbell voice
Cameo at one point in the movie
yes the person that we hear saying
destroyed is actually none other than
Bruce Campbell to make things even
crazier directly Cronin State this might
actually be actually himself Judo all
the time you want me wibbly wobbly stuff
that the franchise does we know that
this record comes from 1923 and they
have teas that they could possibly
explore something like this in an evil
dead six I'd love to see some of the
characters from this coming face to face
with us should we of course get lots of
callbacks to the movies from the outset
the new line logos background turns to a
dark blood red and this is similar to
some of the posters that we've had in
the franchise over the years from here
we go are the woods and this is shown
almost as a POV of something moving
through them which is another style
choice that Remy used in his films the
first movie even start off with
something traveling through the woods
and this happened just before we went
and met our characters now whereas that
had a more Sinister side to it this is a
drone used to introduce us to Teresa
however we get lots of points of view
shots throughout the film echoing how it
was used originally now we catch Theresa
reading Wuthering Heights and this is
later called out by Jessica who recites
passages from the book He's soft
let me in
for pointing out that this could be a
call back to the first film when we saw
cards being counted psychically by
Cheryl
[Music]
I have seen people saying that the
Lakeside could be not to another classic
horror Friday the 13th uh but whether
that's the case or not I think it's
undeniable this cabin is ripping on the
setting of the first two the fisheye
lens effect yeah add so much to this
shot with the forest almost warping
around the entire area this is something
we're getting great effect later on with
the peephole on the door carrying the
same style and when Danny exits the
garage at roughly the 50 minute Mark the
gate going up is framed in a reflection
and it adds the idea that an evil eye is
watching everything now the cabin itself
looks like a pyramid which we're of
course used as tombs by the Pharaohs
it's such a creepy design for the
location and it just adds the ominous
feeling that's made worse by what
happens with Jess on the way though we
get some shots of fly stuck up and this
could be giving an R2 a little technique
that Remy used to use to start the film
he added the sounds of flies buzzing to
make the movies feel even more unnerving
[Applause]
this is something I cronenders himself
but they're not to the fly it's also
being added at the end of the credits
but you know clock up here too which is
likely not to the one from Evil Dead 2
that ends up bleeding this two showed up
in the remake as well and seeing it here
just adds the iconography in the
franchise anyway after Jessica goes on
the attack we get her rising out of the
water mimicking the shot from Apocalypse
Now that movie had lots of symbolism
related to Dante's Inferno and the nine
circles of hell with its centering
around a journey through the Vietnamese
jungle either way it's an awesome way to
start the movie and from here we jump
back to the day before to see guitar
technician Beth learning that she's
pregnant this carries on one of the key
themes throughout the franchise which is
motherhood we of course had this moment
with Beth that all the stuff with Ellie
and beyond that things which have
happened with the other characters
screenran ponied out that Ash's mother
left his family before the events of the
first film and that Annie's mother
Henrietta plays a big part in Evil Dead
2. the 2013 Evil Dead film also centered
around the passing of Mir and David's
mother and it's sort of like poetry they
Rhyme now from here we watch his Beth
visits her sister rally at the Monday
Apartments which is too frame to look
like a pyramid due to the way the camera
films it we get a shot of it from a
wider angle at the 50 minute Mark and
can also see that lamp post is set up to
look like a crucifix this is a reference
to the crucifix that Ash stuck in the
ground earlier in the franchise and
later on in the bank basement we see
several of them later at it now from
here we're entries to Ellie's kid Danny
Bridget and Cassie which Builds on the
idea of siblings throughout the prior
films we've already talked about Mira
and David but the first film had Ash and
his sister Cheryl Mir and Cheryl are
both the first ones to become deadites
in their respective movies and looking
at this film chronologically betsister
Ali is the first two now we get a nice
bit of visual horror with Cassie cutting
off a doll's head which could be a
reference to the beheading we witnessed
at the lake and what we get at the end
YouTube's being funny with our videos at
the moment they keep demonetizing them
even the bloody thing got demonetized
because of Gore so I don't want to show
it but you know what it is and we
learned that she's actually making a
weapon called Stephanie to protect
against an apparent ghost that lives in
the apartment building the idea of a
head being on the bottom of a Sharp
object actually has roots in the
franchise and the Candor and Dagger had
something similar in Danny's room
there's also Three Stooges poster and
Remy admitted that he took a lot of
inspiration from the comedy Trio when he
was making his movies at this point
Bridget then gets invited to go watch
all the Nightmare on Elm Street movies
but she ends up declining it moms and
knights are watching all the Freddy
movies in a row even the shitty ones
there aren't any shitty ones now later
on we get a visual note of this film
with Beth dipping her hand in the
bathtub which he then uses to pretend
that she's being pulled in during Elm
Street we had the iconic bath scene
where Freddy's fingers popped out of the
water and then Nancy got pulled under
which Cronin said he was making bath
imitate and the apartment block is
rocked by gigantic earthquake and this
is something that the cabin suffered at
the end of the second film when
everything was going to hell the idea of
basements being where the evil book is
located is also somewhat of a parallel
to the prior movies with a hatch they're
acting like how the crack does yeah now
he actually get our first in towards a
chainsaw during this scene as we can
catch an image of one on the side of
Thunder's tree surgery van Mr fonder
appears later on the film and he's
actually played by Mark mitchenson who
appeared in Ash vs The Evil Dead on Top
This is actually a number of Easter eggs
here that called back to the earlier
movies you might notice that the
chainsaw has a mustard color to it and
this is different to the red that Ash
ended up carrying however Cronin said
that he used to color here to actually
give it a little nod to the Oldsmobile
Delta radiate this is a car that Remy's
used in all of his movies and it
appeared in the first three Evil Dead
films before showing up as Uncle Ben's
car in Spider-Man it even popped up
during Multiverse of Madness and this
appeared when strange and Christine went
to the destroyed reality although Cronin
didn't fully bring the car across he did
give an odd to this along with another
detail in the name Thunder Peter
Thunder's daughter Bridget was actually
such a big fan of Evil Dead 2 and she
asked to be an Army of Darkness but
unfortunately she couldn't beat the lead
female role in Sheila had already been
cast instead was given a smaller role
and appeared as Linda in the recap
sequences now during this moment we
watch as the kids carrying pizza boxes
which are dropped on the floor when the
earthquake hits when they're going to
pick them up we can see the bottom of
the box says come get some which yet no
prices for guessing what that is come
get some this is something that Beth
also says at the end of the movie when
facing down against the marauder come
get some now there's also Henrietta as
well who as you mentioned earlier was a
character that was taken over by a
deadite she appeared in both the Evil
Dead 2 and then later on in the
franchise during the Ash vs Evil Dead
series she appeared in two with the
iconic hatch scene which opened and
closed just like the lid of a pizza box
okay now this was held together by a
chain and chains are used on the door
later giving us a sort of parallel of
doors and chains being used to hold the
creatures back now when they discover
the bank vault beneath I was legit like
whoa mate don't go down there that's
where the ghost still hears he Keys
jungling is and I know these movies are
purposely goofy but yeah they do have
their nice bits of foreign as well so
down here Danny discovers the book which
we know is one of the three
necronomicons shown in Army of Darkness
these three books have popped up when
we're dealing with the three different
Evil Dead characters this book was of
course what the initial story of Ash was
built around with a second appearing in
the 2030 movie the third appears yeah
and it brings with it its own terrifying
characteristics it really adds to the
atmosphere of it and I love how the
director just does these subtle little
things that he doesn't have to to
elevate the feeling of an ease even
little moments like us cutting to the
elevator and seeing the number 13 lit up
really adds to it and it shows the
attention to detail that they were going
for now if you enjoyed the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
make sure you let us know below if
there's any other horror movies that
you'd like to see us break down I'm
really enjoying going back to the older
movies like aliens the thing The Shining
so if that sounds like the sort of thing
you're into then make sure you hit the
Subscribe button anyway the book is open
with blood and the incantation is played
on a record which calls back to the Evil
Dead 2. and that Ash played a recording
by Professor Nobby which unleashed the
demon similar to what we get here and
that takes us into the elevator scene
which is a clear Riff on the trees seen
from earlier in the franchise not only
do we get another POV shot but we also
get Ali being strung up by wires some of
the how branches were used in that prior
film now Ellie seemingly dies and we get
a fly crawling over her eyeball which to
me is some of the Westworld she gets
stumped in the bathtub but she comes out
reborn and her climbing from the water
is reminiscent of the start of the movie
with Jessica at the cabin now in the
hallway she starts to attack the other
residents and spits out an eyeball which
lands in Jake's mouth this is a call
back to evil at 2 in which we get a
similar thing happening and we also see
Mr Fonda busting out his Boomstick both
of the iconic weapons in the film are
tied in with Fonda with Beth getting her
hands on it before moving onto the
chainsaw anyway at this point we get
Ellie singing a haunting nursery rhyme
which calls back to when Linda sang Ring
Around the Rosies now they really go all
out with everything and give us a moment
that means I'll never look at a cheese
grater in the same way again taking
Bridget down Ellie eventually manages to
get into the apartment through the vents
which leads to one of the creepiest
scenes in the movie depending on what
the brightness on your TV is like you
might have to adjust it but we can see
Ellie sitting in the top Corner as Beth
listens to the records we cut back and
forth between this moment a couple of
times in the scene and later on she
crawls up on this point before she makes
her attack she also says the line I will
swallow your Souls which is of course a
call back to this moment I'll swallow
your soul now Danny passes away after
being fatally wounded by Bridget but at
this moment we get this line by the
deadites
this Rifts on this moment from Evil Dead
2.
dead by Dawn
[Music]
and it's just such a cool call back that
made me cheer a bit when I saw it now
inside the elevator we watch as if I was
up with blood which is a call back to
mine and our editor Matt's favorite
movie that is The Shining and it bursts
open with the blood then gushing out of
it similar the infamous scene from the
horror classic Now Matt runs a channel
that breaks down lots of movies and TV
shows as well over at superhero Nexus so
definitely subscribe if you want to see
more videos like this anyway in the
basement we finally get the chainsaw
scene Against The Marauder along with
that big wood chip a moment with Fonda
being a tree surgeon it makes sense that
he'd have this along with a chainsaw
which is a nice way to explain how it
ended up in an LA apartment building I
also realized at this point that bears
wearing a dark denim color dress which
is visually similar to the denim shirt
that Ash wore in the original trilogy
this leads into that big wood chipper
scene which K comics on Reddit pointed
out could be another scene from Fargo
this is used to kill the marauder and
blood Rains Down out the back of it like
what happens with mirror at the end of
the 2013 movie Beth and Cassie Go off
into an uncertain future and we watch as
Jessica's attacked upon leaving the
buildings setting up the opening of the
film also I think with Beth being called
a groupie that it might be a play on
groovy hey no oh brother this guy stinks
anyway that ends the movie and I hope
the breakdown got a rise out of you and
if you enjoyed it then please drop a
comment below I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you want
something else to watch them make sure
you check out our Brighton of The
Exorcist which will be linked on screen
right now there's lots of subliminal
images and hidden details within it and
yeah lots of things to check out if
you're a big fan of Horror by the way
thank you for sticking through the video
I've been poor let's see you next time
take care peace